I am David Boyle I'm 30 years old I'm a
recruitment manager and I'm on the set
with GQ and Tom Ford Dave is a very
handsome although I have to say he looks
a little older I think that he is he did
say that he thought I looked for years
younger than him which are maybe 48 and
I'm pretty Fey but but it's the
premature great thing that always does
it yeah and the wrinkling around the
eyes I mean you look at him and him on
guy who wears a suit to work a badly
fitting suit I'm afraid but what we
wanted to do with Dave was actually make
him look sexier and more casual and give
them a bit more edge we shoot him on a
bearskin rug by a fire gosh
I'm kidding but I mean that's what I
like I've seen I'd like to see someone
uptight look sexy before today I would
describe my personal style as semi smart
during the week casual on the weekend he
was like oh my suit is slim enough and
you know I'm looking like the guy
walking down the street that has my same
occupation and I think in a way you've
got to take yourself out of your uniform
a lot of guys who wear suits during the
week they go right from a suit to
workout clothes or they just take off
their tie and unbutton their jacket and
stay in their suit on the weekend and
think that's a weekend look so this is
actually a weekend look that you know
most men can wear you spend a bit more
money you get back to quality so I would
definitely say yeah spend a little bit
more you know your clothes will look
better feel better and probably last a
little bit longer as well Dave I think
had some long eyebrows eyebrow bangs I
call them because they hang down
sometimes over your actual eye you
shouldn't pull those individual brow
hairs out which have to do chef
you know your eyebrows are just about
the only thing on your face that is that
is actual facial architecture that can
be changed without cosmetic surgery I
mean this is a very definite thing on
your face it's just brushing them up or
just making sure that they're you know
groom is very important I welcome if tom
was amazing gorgeous now straighten that
head yes oh very handsome
this looks great chin down just to touch
on to do one thing he's directing you
you know I'm not a professional model or
anything so you need to have someone
give you that tip direction and you know
he's a real sound down-to-earth kind of
person as well so it's been great
working with him